au bistrot du théâtre je vous en prie
alizée sery va aller pour une fois c'est
moi qui passa devant nous voilà allez-y
installez-vous là ce nouveau numéro du
café politique 21e numéro aujourd'hui on
va parler de vous de votre parcours de
votre vos engagements mais pas
uniquement on vous êtes né en 64 engagé
à l'est républicain maire de bois d'arcy
depuis 2014 également conseiller
départemental des yvelines depuis 2015
le département des yvelines qui
devraient disparaître en tout cas la
fusion est bien engagée avec les
hauts-de-seine c est un projet porté par
les deux présidents des deux assemblées
est ce que vous vous êtes favorable tout
simplement alors moi je suis favorable à
ce que les deux départements se
rapproche et travaillent ensemble c'est
déjà le cas mais déjà beaucoup de
rapprochement moi même je suis président
divine aménagements qu'est la sem 78 qui
va se rapprocher fusionner avec la sem
92 donc c'est déjà une étape importante
bon je sais pas si les deux départements
vont fusionner puisque les termes quand
même assez fort mais en tout cas les
deux départements se rapproche cette
racine entre il travaille ensemble on a
déjà fait des voeux en commun comme vous
le savez donc procédons par étapes
doucement et on verra après dans
certains élus son coup même dans vos
rangs d'ailleurs sont plutôt opposées
même au sein du conseil à départemental
il souhaiterait un référendum par
exemple parce que là aussi vous être
impliqués référendum à référendum
d'abord tu es remédier ne soit pas alors
vous savez qu'il y a pas d'opposition au
conseil départemental à leur corps tu
n'y a pas d'opposition dit c'est
terrible c'est scandaleux et quand il y
avait les voix qui s'élèvent ondimba
alors qu'est ce qui se passe c'est bien
c'est la démocratie les gens s'expriment
c'est parfait ils réclament un
référendum moi je suis pas tout à fait
favorables parce que les choses doivent
se faire par étapes doucement avec
beaucoup de communication beaucoup de
concertation avec du dialogue
et puis les choses se feront ce ne se
font pas tant pis c'est une bonne idée
en tout cas voilà il faut retenir que
c'est une bonne idée on parle des
départements on peut aussi s'arrêter
quelques instants sur la question de
l'intercommunalité saint quentin en
yvelines s'est élargie mais bois d'arcy
n'a pas rejoint saint quentin en
yvelines bois d'arcy qui fait partie de
versailles grand parc pourquoi pas
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout ça on n'a
rien demandé
ne mettez pas dans un
bara on n'a rien demandé du tout il faut
savoir faut faire un peu d'histoire
monard cité dans le san de saint quentin
il ya une trentaine quarantaine d'années
au tout début de la ville nouvelle où
tout début de la ville nouvelle et puis
par référendum justement à l'époque
monarchique sortie du san
en laissant le pas du lac donc ne pas
black est devenu montigny on a gardé
juste un petit bout du pas du lac qui
est le jardins familiaux voilà et puis
maintenant on est très très bien dans
versailles grand parc on forme une très
grosse agglomération 19 villes de 170
mille habitants avec l'entrée cette
année vélizy non c'est bien c'est pas
mal quand même parce que certaines
communes ont quitté leur île aux la
ville nouvelle à l'époque justement je
pense à à maurepas ou à coignières ils
sont revenus avec le nouveau découpage
je vous pose cette question pour 51
parce que vous connaissez bien le bassin
de 50 m oui oui il avait été directeur
de la communication et long cours
pendant sept ans 2006 à 2013 et vous
avez à travailler avec ghrib rigueur
étiez donc qui est devenu depuis maire
de merpins
voilà donc le service communication de
la ville d'elancourt qui s est
positionné dans l'ordre alors attendez
l'autobus savais pas ce que je vois où
vous voulez en venir parce que je suis
scandalisé et ses militants à maurepas
et moi j'étais moi-même militants bois
d'arcy quand on a travaillé en sciences
et sur cette phase on sort du bassin de
saint quentin en yvelines même si ce
sont deux agglomérations distincts que
vous vous travaillez avec 50 ans nous on
travaille beaucoup et ça quand on nie
d'abord parce qu'on est on est on est
frontalier de 50 ans et quand vous voyez
la carte de 2,50 à il ya une espèce de
2,2 de deux trous ou presque au milieu
c'est bois d'arcy
donc c'est vrai qu'on travaille
énormément avec 50,1 on est un peu moi
j'ai tendance à dire pour pour rigoler
à versailles grand parc on est un peu
l'alsace-lorraine de la bri de
versailles grand parc
quelques mots sur l'actualité la
déchéance de nationalité la prolongation
de l'état d'urgence les discussions sont
odieux en ce moment dans les différentes
assemblées nationales les députés se
penchent sur la question les sénateurs
aussi quelques parce qu'on regarde sur
sa jambe avant je suis pour écourt voilà
sur les deux questions vous avez géré de
la nationalité sont jetés dans les
geôles idée d'ailleurs à mes voeux je
suis pour la déchéance de la nationalité
tout d'abord parce que parce que
lorsqu'on s'attaque à la communauté
nationale ne mérite pas de faire partie
de cette communauté nationale
après dans l'est dans les détails
juridiques je suis parent législateur
mais mais c'est vrai que dans le
principe je suis plutôt pour la
déchéance de nationalité
ces gens doivent sortir de la communauté
nationale n'ont rien à y faire
soit deuxième question c'est elle sur la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence de
l'inscription dans la constitution
oui aussi je suis favorable ça on est
dans une situation exceptionnelle il
faut prendre des mesures exceptionnelles
et je pense que le gouvernement a raison
de de l'inscrire dans la constitution
mais en levant toutes ces pierres
sacrées distance sur différents partis
politiques ça affaiblit aussi peut-être
le gouvernement est ce que c'est une
bonne réponse le clivage est dans l'es2
quand vous avez remarqué l'état le
clivage est dans la droite ni dans la
gauche mais moi je suis plutôt favorable
sur les deux alors je connais peut-être
pas grand-chose mais en tout cas c'est
mon avis personnel
on va laisser de côté cette telle
actualité on va faire juste une courte
pause je vous laisse passer en salle à
présent à l'exercice
philippe benassaya élu maire de bois
d'arcy en mars 2014 donc vous avez fait
basculer cette commune qui était à
gauche depuis 1995 lorsque vous avez
décidé de conquérir cette ville
à aucun moment vous avez douté de votre
victoire il ya des territoires plus
facile quand on veut devenir mère alors
si j'avais entendu les observateurs
politiques médiatiques et cetera je
devais perdre ça c'est déjà une
motivation supplémentaire ça ça me
motive
oui parce que en fait je savais alors
bien sûr on est toujours doute toujours
jusqu'au dernier moment c'est normal
cessé la compétition
mais le contexte était favorable à un
basculement contexte politique contexte
sociologique bois d'arcy était en train
de changer
l'usure du pouvoir aussi et puis avait
aussi un problème générationnel
voilà donc qui moi j'étais sûre de moi
mais on n'arrêtait pas de me dire que
j'allais perdre que ça me motive et dix
fois plus merci vous y êtes arrivé en
cette commune où vous en avez pensé quoi
tout simplement en arrivant lorsque vous
l'avez découvert bercy on en parle
souvent dans l'actualité alors pour
caricaturer c'est avec elle le centre de
détention la prison qui est installée
mais il n'ya pas que ça à bois d'arcy
qu'à l'image vous aviez de dollars 6
alors moi je suis arrivé en 2008 j'étais
sur la liste déjà municipales en 2008 on
avait lourdement perdu d'ailleurs et
c'est ça qui m'a donné envie d'y
retourner parce que je trouvais que
c'était injuste parce que je savais
qu'il y avait quelque chose on pouvait
faire quelque chose à bonnart 6 quand
j'y suis merci beaucoup
quand j'y suis quand j'y suis arrivé
j'ai trouvé une ville d'abord plutôt
paisible sympathique en bordure de forêt
mais très endormi 13 endormi et un petit
peu on va dire
un peu suranné un peu dépassé on a
l'impression quand on rentre à bois
d'arcy qu'on change un peu d'époque
voilà donc mon objectif a été de dire
dès le début qu'il fallait faire rentrer
bonnart cédant matinée ème siècle
j'aimerais revenir sur ce moment où vous
recevez votre écharpe de maire le moment
où se déroule la passation véritablement
de pouvoir le journal le parisien qui
titrait son article la simplicité de
philippe benassaya
vous n'êtes pas dans les grandes
démonstrations les grands discours ça me
colle bien ça ça vous correspond bien je
crois qu'il faut pas changer la
simplicité société voilà si on change cc
factice un fake comme on dit aujourd'hui
dans le langage d'aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il faut rester soi-même pour rester
soi même alors j'aime bien les discours
j'aime bien écrire j'aime bien parler
j'aime bien
j'aime bien dialoguer mais je crois
qu'il faut rester soi même et puis j'ai
pas envie de changer moi je suis bien
comme je suis entré cité cendrier
tellement pas faire de vagues
je n'ai pas de code voilà pas de code
que pensent les habitants de votre
travail
à les écouter on a là bas de la jeunesse
voilà ça change de l'ancienne équipe
assez anciennes affiches et son nom
placardées dans toute la ville me
dérange puis tous les problématiques
financières sont reportés sur la faute
d'avant la faute du gouvernement il a
quand même fait beaucoup de choses et il
essaie de rénover un petit peu notre
ville ce qui est quand même pas
désagréable à on bouge un petit peu plus
et s'impose non pas en commenter je peux
vous dire que je pourrais lui montrer ma
feuille mois en 2015 ils ont augmenté
mais c'est pas moi 125 euros
si vous veniez sans qu'il y ait une
équipe quand même
je tiens beaucoup plus jeune et beaucoup
plus à l'ordre du jour en fait on y
assure la jeunesse voilà c'est sûr c'est
pas mal de confusion où il possède pas
il faut savoir une chose c'est que les
gens ne comprennent pas toujours ce
qu'on vit c'est normal et puis peut-être
qu'on communique mal et peut être que
les choses sont un peu compliquées pour
pau et complexe pour les gens là là là
là finances publiques et est compliquée
déjà pour moi alors j'imagine pour pour
les personnes qui ne sont pas élus qui
n'ont pas en prise directe sur les sur
les dossiers oui c'est vrai je passais
pas vous que je le dire mais c'est vrai
qu'on a perdu et cette année plus d'un
million d'euros de baisses des dotations
d'état
et c'est vrai qu'on est à un million
d'euros c'est à peu près le budget
d'entretien des écoles
oui un peu ce qu'on perd donc c'est vrai
que malheureusement madame je suis
désolé mais on a perdu un million
d'euros voilà et donc c'est de plus en
plus compliqué mais on arrive à tenir
puisqu'on ne n'augmente pas les impôts
et ça je crois que les artésiens l'envi
sur la part de la commune sur la part de
la cobas gabriela question du
département sur une société aussi hélas
les impôts augmentent hélas les impôts
augmentent il faut savoir que le
département a perdu 90% de sa ca dgf ce
qui est une régression globale de
fonctionnement on en revient à cette
question de rapprochement avec les
hauts-de-seine mais aussi dans cette
optique de faire des économies votre
engagement politique début des années 80
à l'udf
oui puis à l'ump pour moi le choix de
cette tendance politique
comment ça c'est fait laquelle du des
fdf d'abord et puis après alors et l'ump
moi j'ai commencé à militer en politique
que la fin des zones à la fin des années
70 début 80 j'avais 17 18 ans je m'étais
engagé dans la campagne de valéry
giscard d'estaing
j'en ai écrit deux livres donc voila
c'était une très belle période
et puis après je me suis engagé un peu
dans les associations humanitaires et
droits de l'homme en fait de j'avais
commencé à militer pour en faveur des
réfugiés ni l'urss à l'époque c'est
cesser ces gens qui étaient emprisonnés
dans un goulag pour liberté d'expression
voilà donc et ça ça m'a ramené
directement à l'udf avec à l'époque des
gens comme françois léotard et autres
qui étaient très très humanitaire là
dessus très très très humanitaire et
puis ensuite c'est les aléas de la vie
politique des rencontres les pros
et j'ai déconnecté de l'udf en 2007
lorsque françois bayrou a a fait un
choix politique qui n'était pas le mien
voilà donc je suis parti rejoindre l'ump
et j'ai voté nicolas sarkozy en 2007
vous êtes bien dans cette famille très
bien qui rateraient même petit depuis il
a changé de nom pour devenir les
républicains boutique avoir assez
chaotique c'est vrai parce que la grèce
en mai wemhoff à la vie politique est
chaotique de manière générale on le voit
à gauche on voit à droite on le voit au
centre c'est chaotique mais oui j'y suis
bien parce que ça cette cette famille
politique qui se construira semble à peu
près les valeurs qui sont les miennes
pour les valeurs de liberté d'entreprise
de mérite de réussite c'est ça me plaît
plutôt mai et nicolas sarkozy c'est
aussi une personnalité que vous soutenez
dans l'optique de 2017 s'il se
présentait officiellement la primaire
alors je vous réponds très très très
honnêtement je vais attendre un peu les
primaires pour voir comment ça se passe
parce qu'on a de très bons candidats on
à la jupe et on à son nom sur fion wii
sont nombreux et françois fillon nicolas
sarkozy etc
faudrait savoir ce sur quoi il se hisse
eux ils s'engagent après je ferai mon
choix mais la personnalité plus sur les
valeurs le programme une fonction des
conventions et beaucoup travaillent en
2017 mais de toute façon quel que soit
le candidat après qui sortira des
primaires je voterai pour lui on évoquer
votre arrivée à la tête de bonnart si
vous avez fait basculer la commune de
gauche à droite l'année suivante vous
faites la même chose avec le canton 2 de
saint cyr bonnart 6 appartient ce canton
vous devenez conseiller départemental ou
l'emporter face à un socialiste jean
philippe mallet l'ancien député
suppléant de benoît hamon
pourquoi cette volonté de devenir
conseiller départemental aussi parce
qu'on vous l'a demandé
déjà non enfin la vendre et et ses
candidats oui non non c'est pas ça qui
m'a motivé j'ai toujours dit que et ça
plusieurs fois je pense j'ai toujours
dit que le tandem mer en conseiller
général voire conseiller départemental
maintenant était un bon tandem c'était
un bon cumul d'abord parce que la
majorité des projets municipaux sont
soutenus à dos et au département
donc il me fallait franchement il me
fallait être conseiller départemental
pour imposer mes projets c'est le cas
d'ailleurs avec certains projets
peut-être avoir parlé des projets
sociaux sportifs des projets numériques
qui sont soutenues et financées par le
département je veux dire que la commune
est avantagée par ce que vous signez au
conseil départemental
lorsqu'on est maire et conseiller
départemental ça va un petit peu plus
vite mais lorsqu'on est maire et
conseiller départemental dans la
majorité
j'aime beaucoup jean philippe val est
d'ailleurs c'est quelqu'un que je
respecte beaucoup d'ailleurs mais il
était dans l'opposition à l'époque et je
sais pas s'il a fait beaucoup avancer
avancer la ville prendre des
responsabilités politiques est ce que
c'était une volonté vous avez eu assez
assez rapidement parce qu'avant d'être
élu vous étiez journaliste politique
assistants parlementaires aussi
directeur de cabinet dont des
collectivités avec un moment où vous
vous êtes dit j'en ai marre d'être dans
l'ombre et je me prendre un peu la
lumière d'un mois j'ai eu plusieurs vies
ça c'est vrai j'étais journaliste j'ai
travaillé j'ai travaillé dans les
cabinets ministériels jette assistance
et un parlementaire et puis j'ai aussi
j'ai aussi monté ma boîte de
communication institutionnelle j'ai
écrit des livres
voilà donc moi j'ai pris ça comme des
comme des expériences comme des
expériences très enrichissantes
alors peut-être que ça peut-être que
tout ça était une formation à devenir
élus peut-être en passer par là sur le
mandat généraux il n'y avait pas de
calcul mais c'est vrai que peut-être que
tout ça était un long cheminement vers
vers une élection
peut-être une formation première c'est
l'histoire oui ou d'un débat à la
sorbonne
oui on sait bien en sait rien 4 paris
terrasse paris iv nous en parler un peu
que c'est cette année le très belle
année les années 80 paris iv la sorbonne
on est l histoire est une passion pour
lui oui oui parce que l'histoire sais
c'est pas simplement un livre d'histoire
et puis d epuis une chronologie c'est
surtout s'il connaît une connaissance du
monde une facilité à écrire à dialoguer
à réfléchir analyser à à privilégier la
critique critique historique
et puis avec une passion pour l'histoire
contemporaine et notamment la troisième
république et vous avez publié notamment
les années giscard
oui un livre consacré à valéry giscard
d'estaing et le regard plutôt
bienveillant sur valéry giscard
d'estaing puisque vous revenez sur les
avancées majeures 18 ans légalisation de
l'avortement libéralisation de
l'information divorce par consentement
mutuel
il y avait beaucoup de choses qui ont
été oubliés par la suite sur valéry
giscard d'estaing
c'est peut-être pas le président qui
revient le plus souvent dans le droite
plus populaires de ces dernières années
pourquoi ce regard si on valéry giscard
d'estaing oublié parce que il et valéry
giscard d'estaing était coincé entre le
gaullisme précédent et le socialisme et
donc on a fait de valéry giscard
d'estaing une parenthèse une parenthèse
politique alors que c'était pas une
parenthèse je pense que moi la première
grande alternance sous la 5ème
république c'est valérie jusqu'à mais ça
et c'est par françois mitterrand c'est
valéry giscard d'estaing parce qu'ils
abhorraient imposer un nouveau style une
nouvelle politique française il a fait
monter une nouvelle génération
et puis quand vous avez égrainé tous les
projets tous les projets toutes les
réformes de valérie giscard et ça c'est
un truc incroyable je suis persuadé que
la postérité rendra justice à ce
septennat peut-être pas à l'homme parce
qu'on a tous nos failles et tout ce
défaut mais la postérité rendra à mon
avis hommage à 7 à cette base n'est pas
la place qu'ils méritent aujourd'hui
d'abord il a été étrillé par les médias
qui ne caricature pas aujourd'hui valéry
giscard d'estaing ça a été un grand
septennat très honnêtement alors
bienveillant oui pourquoi pas mais
critique aussi parce qu'il ya eu aussi
des erreurs comme dans tout septennat il
ya eu beaucoup d'erreurs et beaucoup de
maladresses et beaucoup de et beaucoup
de 2,2 ce no scandale
l affaire des diamants et un pseudo
scandale qui n'a jamais existé par
exemple on va écouter justement un petit
micro-trottoir que pensaient les gens de
valéry giscard d'estaing camara
voilà pourquoi je pense que c'était un
bon président maintenant les politiciens
sont ils sont très intéressés de pour
eux peut-être la majorité à 18 ans et
avoir créé un ministère de des femmes et
nos me giroux que j'aimais beaucoup la
loi de simone veil -le principal
moi je trouve que dans l'ensemble
c'était un homme intelligent et les
diamants de bokassa ses frasques avec
lady diana que des frasques
ce dont je me souviens c'est un petit
déjeuner avec les éboueurs à paris voilà
le fait marquant de monsieur giscard
d'estaing au revoir il est très bien
votre micro trottoir parce qu'il résume
totalement ce que les médias ont voulu
retenir de valéry giscard d'estaing au
revoir les diamants et lady diana
voilà et puis à la deuxième c'est très
bien fait parce qu'il ya des deux il ya
des deux volets et puis il ya ceux qui
ont vraiment réfléchi à ce septennat et
ceux qui en ont retenu les grands
projets c'est bien c'est un modèle
valéry giscard d'estaing ou pas pour
vous on a parlé tout à l'heure nicolas
sarkozy votre modèle en politique
est-ce qu'il y en a déjà oui mais sont
ils sont ils sont très loin et centrales
vont ils sont orientés rapide et des
décennies
non un modèle un modèle non mais par
contre le latitude la posture politique
la génération politique oui celle de
giscard en 74 ça a été un grand vent de
liberté un très grand risque à celle de
jacques chirac
oui je pense parce que valéry giscard
d'estaing si on s'éloigne des poncifs
médiatique il a renversé la table
très honnêtement on a renversé la table
il a il a créé il a créé des
secrétariats d'état des ministères il a
fait monter les femmes
il a fait beaucoup de choses dans une
période qui était plus pencher plutôt à
gauche à l'époque on était dans les
années 70 on est un petit peu chevelu on
est un peu les années pop mais c'était
c'était un grand président il a créé
l'europe la montée l'europe avec les
loups de schmidt et ça c'est quand même
quelque chose d'important mais jacques
chirac vous étiez dans son staff de
campagne vis en 95 j'étais dans le staff
de campagne de médias avec avec chirac
là aussi il ya des envies mais il y
avait des similitudes d'ailleurs je
pense puisque vous me posez la question
je pense qu'il ya plus de la plus de
similitudes avec le sarkozy de 2007
vis-à-vis de giscard d'estaing que
chirac les avis de giscard il y avait la
même après bon après les périodes sous
différentes concernant les républicains
on l'a évoqué brièvement vous nous avez
dit vous vous attendez de voir les
propositions de chacun vous parliez de
valéry giscard d'estaing qui avait
renversé la table aujourd'hui ce qu'il
faut encore quelqu'un pour renverser la
table passe comme candidat qui arrive le
plus en tête en tout cas si la primaire
devaient avoir lieu demain ce sera alain
juppé oui un juriste 70 ans
oui je re je crains pour alain juppé
d'être trop appuyée par le système et
par les milliards sont en général sa
porte pas bonheur ou aux candidats
vous avez un regard critique sur les
médias dont qui avaient été gelées oui
un petit peu parce que laure un grand
gars critique pas sur le métier bien sûr
de journalistes que j'ai été sur les
images
ouais je trouve qu'on est trop dans
l'écumé des choses est trop dans le
sensationnel dans le people mois
maintenant qu'ils tissus et lui je le
vois moi même journalistique m'en parle
ans lorsqu'on a un gros projet un projet
important il n'est pas relaté lorsqu'on
a une polémique à les relater mais c'est
le jeu je ne critique pas assez le jeu
mais ce jeu là je peux politiques en jeu
seulement voilà ils savent pas grand
chose si on devait choisir je
préférerais qu'on parle des projets
justement vos projets concernant cette
commune si on parle du fond sur votre
travail et la lld chose que vous n'avez
encore à accomplir sur la suite de votre
mandat
heureusement parce que ça fait deux ans
alors oui ça fait que que deux ans mais
c'est vrai que bois d'arcy a énormément
changé en deux ans alors je le dis sur
ce support objectif
je suis d'accord je suis d'accord je
suis pas très objectif mais c'est vrai
que je le vois d'ailleurs sur ce micro
trottoir
les gens ont les gens cette perception
que les choses sont en train de changer
à bois d'arcy alors qu'est ce qui change
à bois d'arcy d'abord écouter on a mis
le paquet pardonnez moi l'expression sur
sur la modernité on a on a changé nos
outils de communication on a on a fait
du numérique dans les écoles on a créé
l'application est importante
après non mais c'est très très bien pour
distinguer la communication de la
formation et c'est ces différentes mais
la communication doit s'appuyer sur du
fond s'il n'y a pas de fonds n'y a pas
de communication il ya la police
municipale on a fait beaucoup de
chaussures cadre de vie on vient
d'obtenir la première fleur au concours
des villes et villages fleuris donc vous
voyez ça bouge pas mal
et puis on est en train de retour à
l'été cette ville et la protéger voilà
c'est pour ça que moi j'ai supprimé
beaucoup de projets urbains
parce que je n'avais pas envie que notre
ville perdre son identité et donc on est
en train de revoir tous les projets à la
baisse pour pouvoir protéger l'identité
de bonheur si le prochain grand projet
alors on a manqué de sony vous est fixé
avant la fin de la fin du mandat
alors le sait au niveau sportif qu'on va
beaucoup bouger parce qu'on est en train
de rénover notre grand gymnase est on en
train de créer une piste d'athlétisme
donc c'est quand même déjà beaucoup et
puis on va bien évidemment continuer à
travailler sur cadre de vie parce que ça
c'est très important et puis
le scolaire et puis bien d'autres choses
et la voirie on a une grande avenue sur
bois d'arcy qui va être refaite l'année
prochaine dont je pense que à la fin du
mandat après c'est des électeurs qui
décident mais la fin du monde
d'abord darcis aura totalement changé
padam padam et de 2,2 d'image vous
parlez du sport ça fait partie de votre
vos passions c'est ce que vous avez
écrit noir sur blanc lors de notre
candidature quand vous êtes adressé aux
assises et un patio dossier laisse à sa
cause escrime et musique classique wii
sur l'actualité du football alors on va
parler de ça peut-être l'euro en france
en 2016 l'euro à oui biensur bien sûr
que je suis même une équipe qui serait
bien j'ai pas loin de bois d'arcy assez
sur facebook ou bien leur dire non non
non je vais suivre le rouge sur un
cheval fans de foot depuis petit la
première fois je suis allé au parc des
princes parce que bien évidemment je
vous faire des ennemis mais je suis
plutôt pg je suis là et au parc des
princes est en 1974 je crois avec la
grande équipe du psg de l'époque avec un
peu les dahleb puis j'aime beaucoup les
scream aussi j'en ai fait j'en ai fait
pendant plusieurs années
c'est un très joli sport très physique
et l'équipe du psg aujourd'hui elle vous
plaît oui oui même si les critiques et
financement c'est normal on peut on peut
pas avoir le beurre et l'argent du
beurre donc pour construire une grande
équipe il faut de grands moyens et le
psg en a un entraîneur je pense très bon
entraîneur
et puis une très belle équipe mais nous
manque un bon résultat européen
voilà ce que au nouveau championnat je
pense que c'est plié on dit
équipe lilloise aussi un paris
saint-germain installer un saint germain
on verra où sera le prochain camp
d'entraînement si vous avez des infos du
département puisque certains conseillers
départementaux qui suivent le dossier
avec beaucoup beaucoup d'attention
notamment du côté de poissy je suis une
dernière question puisqu'on parle cette
équipe de france et c'est tout même
l'image de la france au delà du sportif
on parle beaucoup des affaires
extra-sportives la sphère balbuena
benzema en tant que responsable
politique allemand qui veut que les
livraisons c'est que lorsqu'on regarde
l'équipe de france des années 80
70 alors peut-être qu'elle n'était pas
connue des affaires là pour le coup
c'est vrai que c'était peut-être plus
plus sourdes plus cacher mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya vait j'ai l'impression qu'il y
avait une éthique peut-être un petit peu
plus leur jeu
je dis pas que c'était mieux avant c'est
mais aujourd'hui si tu es mieux
aujourd'hui l'équipe de france est une
très belle équipe
je trouve que les faits divers et sont
un peu dommageable pour cette équipe il
faudrait qu'une plus grande discipline
chez ces footballeurs là vous avez une
petite nostalgie du passé
non non non malheureusement dufour il a
essayé de la politique il faut bien
connaître le passé à mon avis pour bien
préparer l'avenir et je pense que c'est
pour ça que je me réfère de temps en
temps parce que on y apprend des choses
on y apprend des choses il faut pas
oublier le passé on a un vrai devoir de
mémoire
quand on est citoyen et encore plus
quand on est année ce sera la conclusion
de ce café politique merci filet mais
non merci beaucoup merci
à